[Music]
hey guys what's up I'm Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle we give
you the best tips on grooming style
fitness and a modeling life now if
you're new to the channel please
subscribe so that you won't miss
anything new and in this video we're
gonna talk about how to look good in
photos for men and we're starting right
now
[Music]
alright so there's a couple of tips that
you can do to take better photos now
number one these the light the light is
the most important thing when it comes
to taking photos like right now I'm
standing in front of a big window right
so the light comes in everything is
clear but let me turn the camera around
and you see how it looks if I turn
around focus on my face you see how
that's that just looks look terrible
right even if I turn it to the side you
can see the light coming in here but
then this side is very dark so when
you're in door stand in front of the
window where the light is better now if
you're out door it's better to try and
take the photos in the shade because the
sunlight is not so strong on your face
and the light is a lot better you never
take photos in direct sunlight because
you'll get all these kind of shadows
here and in your face and that'll really
looks terrible so what you want to do is
take photos when the Sun is at the back
of your head and not in front the second
tip is grooming in style with the right
grooming and of the right styling is
just a little bit of effort but you can
look so much better in photos tip number
three is your posture and the angles
together what do I mean well it depends
on if you're a bigger guy I've got a lot
of muscles or if you're slim and skinny
right if you're bigger you want to have
this posture of really bringing these
shoulders a little bit back standing up
straight and just looking a lot better
with your posing your face and your
shoulders and your chest everything goes
together they work together as a team so
it's really good to look straight onto
the camera but also the angles of your
face look a little bit down with a
little bit
or a little bit up especially if you
live far away all right but if you're a
skinny guy what you want to do is you
can move a lot more than the bigger guys
and you won't look strange but what I
mean is you can change and play with the
angles rise you can stand like this and
you can walk you can do a lot more
because you wanted to look so weird you
can tilt a little bit back with your
back and look at the camera and look
there and you can try all these kind of
interesting and different angles you can
even bring the hands up you can play
around and you can do everything that's
kind of weird and interesting and fits
in with you a lot more it's a little bit
more closer to high fashion modeling
where it's more interesting right now
the angles of your body is always like
45 to the camera and 45 left right if
you missed my video from my old model
poses for beginners go check it out so
you can learn about these angles and
then for your face if you look straight
to the camera sometimes it's better to
tilt your head a little bit down like
that and to the side too like that or
this way but play around with the angles
see what works best with your face type
and your body type that's something that
you have to do and I cannot explain to
you how to do that just play around and
see what works and that takes us to the
fourth tip facial expressions some guys
look good by being very friendly and
smiley and everything is just all good
right and some guys look better when
they are more serious right
but even though you have these
expressions there's a lot that you can
do with your eyes so I'm gonna do some
of these expressions let's start with
the basic ones where it's kind of the
cool look right so what you want to
think about while you do this pose is
just think about something that looks
really cool or I don't know use your
imagination right so you look somewhere
and you're more serious right but now
you play of your eyes so you make your
eyes stronger so you do this you see the
difference in how your eye look right so
you can play around with your eyes a lot
to give a better impression
[Music]
if you look friendly you do the same
thing you just smile a little bit and
look at the camera but don't always look
at the camera look away a little bit you
know and just be friendly and think
about things that make you happy that's
how you have these facial expressions
that are natural because it is how you
are really like right that's what you
want to do it looks somewhere think
about things that make you happy even if
that's food for me sometimes I think
about my family that I missed back home
because doing modeling you have to
travel a lot in foreign and I don't see
my family a lot so I think about them
sometimes and it makes me happy right
being happy never goes out of style
but he used the expressions that works
the best of you with your face type move
you're kind of look alright alright my
fifth tip is editing you can edit your
pictures to make it look a little bit
better you know like after light and
facetune those kind of stuff just
download the app you can edit it but
don't go just crazy you know it needs to
look natural I mean there's a lot of
fake stuff out there that's just fake
you know and people trying to be someone
who they're not and you don't want
people to like your photos or like your
picture but it doesn't even look like
you alright so keep it nice keep it
natural so I would only use it if I'm at
a very dark place and how it looks on
the phone is not how it looks in real
life right so I would edit it so that it
looks natural that's what you want to do
especially on Instagram there are these
people who edit everything they make
their butts bigger they make their
shoulders bigger they just go crazy and
so you don't you never know what is real
on Instagram anymore don't do that
people want things that are real there's
too many of the fake stuff people like
things that are real that is true
so focus on that alright let's go to tip
number six if someone else is taking the
picture ask them to count it down you
know because sometimes there's someone
who wants to take the picture and you
guys are ready and they did you're
standing and visitor focusing and
just figuring it out but everybody is
waiting and they have their facial
expressions and then with time it's
gonna you lose it it's like you know
those pageants when the girls start out
and they smile and it looks nice and
natural right but after a wild they've
been walking on the stage for a while
they get tired so you can see when the
natural drops to being abnormal and
weird right so is natural smiling and it
is this kind of weird face so that is
what happens if you don't ask someone to
tell you the exact moment when they take
the picture so when they take the
picture they have to say ok 1 2 3
done my seventh tip is the background
the background is so important it needs
to fit in with your style right so let's
say the background here is more
corporate right so I put on this kind of
jacket it looks better because now it
fits in right so if I take the photo in
here you'll be ok right if I just change
the angle a little bit if I would
standing here with the jacket and with
the background it'll be a lot better so
so you can just play around with the
expressions and you can take the photo
so the background is very important
sometimes you want an interesting
background because it shows people who
you are and your personality it's not
just boring and fake so you can walk in
the street or you walk on you can walk
in the road and take some photos as well
especially if you're in a different
country here the Sun is the best
see that
here it's terrible sometimes a clean
clear bag around it like this he's also
cool all right my eighth tip is being
natural just be normal be you all right
oh my goodness I cannot say that more
I've seen some of the YouTube videos and
they some of these poses it's just it
looks so fake and unnatural good when
the people are walking is like weird
kind of strange walk work or they fake
and then they look so stiff what you
want to do is just be who you really are
in real life and take that shot nothing
is better than that
[Music]
so if you just stand you know stand and
smile and take the picture
if you walk somewhere you look do it the
way you would really do it
[Music]
don't be too stressed about being
perfect and having the perfect shot and
these people who are so obsessed with it
it's it's like crazy so when you take
photos don't just take photos of you all
the time itself is just you you you you
because for other people you'll bill you
look like you're obsessed with yourself
so take photos with people show the
backgrounds show where you are what are
you doing what's going on in your life
make it more interesting there are
millions of people out there that take
selfies and photos of themselves every
day right but what makes you different
from everybody else but your life is
your story because you are unique and
there's nobody else out there like you
all right okay guys if you like the
video give me a thumbs up subscribe and
then I'll see you in the next video
you